they call it the toughest job in
Washington not the presidency but those
who control access to it the White House
chief of staff plays a critical role in
the success or failure of any
administration author Chris Whipple
spoke with all 17 living people who've
held the title for his new book the
gatekeepers how the White House chiefs
of staff define every presidency and he
joins us here this morning Chris welcome
thanks for having one of the first
chiefs of staff were introduced to in
the book is HR Bob Haldeman who many of
us remember from Watergate but he
actually really helped define and sort
of the modern terms this job didn't he
that's the really fascinating thing
about Haldeman and and and the book is
really about fascinating characters from
from beginning to end but hold him in
among the most because he was as we all
know sort of the poster boy for
Watergate the biggest scandal in
political history and yet the irony is
that he created the template for the
modern empowered White House chief and
if you talk to his successors they will
all say that guy wrote the book he knew
more about how to what did he do for
Richard Nixon I mean essentially well
what he among other things what he did
was he created time and space for Nixon
to think you know he created he was the
ultimate gatekeeper he he was able to
make the trains run on time he was a
gatekeeper he controlled the flow of
information to the president he executed
the president's agenda and he and he ran
a very tight ship until of course it all
unraveled a lot of people forget that
Dick Cheney and Don Rumsfeld were chief
of staff under Gerald Ford how formative
was that experience and how much did it
determine the men that they became later
well talk about untold stories and
surprising stories Dick Cheney as a 34
year old White House chief of staff -
yeah - Gerald Ford was believe it or not
the most popular guy in town he was the
life of the party he was he he had a
self effacing manner he was the guy you
wanted in the room when you when you
needed to reach a consensus he was he
good service code name was backseat so
it's become a kind of it's become a kind
of almost a parlor game among all the
Chiefs themselves or what in the world
happened to Cheney yeah there are a lot
of different theories each other you
tell a great story about how after Ford
lost Cheney left a broken bike wheel
behind with a note wouldn't know well
Gerald Ford had this crazy notion as it
turned out a lot of presidents have made
the same mistake but Gerald Ford thought
he could have five or six or more senior
advisors with equal access to him coming
and going does it that sound familiar
anyway and they he called it the spokes
of the wheel yes right it was a disaster
and it took Gerald Ford a month to
figure that out and and he turned
everything around by bringing in guess
who Don Rumsfeld too just to put the
White House together but on Dick
Cheney's last day spokes of the wheel
became such a in joke
Dick Cheney was presented with a mangled
bicycle wheel with every spoke broken he
took it and instead of taking at home
and putting it in the garage he left it
on his desk and he wrote a note to his
successor ham Jordan saying dear ham
beware the spokes of the wheel on that
note I have to ask you given the news
this week there's like almost a reported
Game of Thrones style power struggle
happening inside the Trump White House
featuring his chief of staff
Reince Priebus how unusual does that
seem in the context of what you
researched in the book it's it's it's
not unusual it's it's happened before
and it's a formula for failure to have
equal access you know the notion that
you're governing is it's very hard
governing is not like running a real
estate firm in Manhattan and it you
can't have a bunch of lieutenants at war
with each other and somehow expect that
that's creative tension the White House
doesn't work that way the lesson a major
lesson of the book for me is that every
president learns often the hard way that
you have to
power your chief-of-staff to be first
among equals in the White House so that
he can execute your agenda and also tell
you what you don't want to hear are
there ever gonna be any female Chiefs of
Staff yes I'm sure I mean I'm sure why
has there went so far T yeah
well how many you know how many female
presidents have we had and for that
matter how many female campaign managers
have we had not many and I think that'll
that'll change and it almost happened
reportedly under Obama and there was a
woman named nancy-ann DeParle who was
who was behind the health care bill and
she just didn't have the political
experience really for the job she had
lots of policy experience all right
Chris Whipple thank you so much the book
is the gatekeepers and it is available
now